(lighthearted music)
- In three months you can...
- Three months?
I haven't got three months. (laughs)
- Right side.
- Hi, my name is Fabio.
We are in my restaurant Figli Del Vesuvio.
I start to work pizza chef when I was 14.
For six month, I work free just for learn this job.
- Tell me how to spin a pizza then.
- I start with plastic pizza.
Two, three hour a day, I was always try.
- And it took you...
- Two, three month with the plastic pizza.
After three month, yes, I start to with dough.
If you want, I can show you now.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- This is our dough...
- Okay.
- that I make yesterday.
- The dough is light because we do 24-hour fermentation.
(pizza dough slaps)
- The pizza get better.
- So, show me without the pizza.
- When the mean time you put the pizza in the left hand,
you already to turn.
When you finish with left, start with right.
- (laughs) It's not gonna happen.
- I think it's better you start with a cloth.
The right hand, you put in the left.
You start to turn.
All one way, just with the end of finger.
- You make it look so easy.
- (laughs) Yeah, after three months,
for you it will be easy as well.
- Oh, pfft!
- This is it again. (laughs)
- Look at this.
- Okay, right hand, left hand, spin.
- You see?
- I think I'm ready for the dough
^- [Man] Are you sure?
- (laughs) No.
- Pick the dough a little the flour.
Now, do a circular settee.
Start from up to down.
Great.
Take this side, oh, you do the same like before.
Okay, now if you follow also.
- Okay.
- Push.
- Mine is not go very well. (laughs)
- It's hard, but in three months you can.
- Three months?
I haven't got three months.
Right side, like this.
- Spin?
- Spin and push on the right,
left, right, left. (laughs)
- Pfft! (moans)
Spin, straight away?
- There you go.
- Oh god!
- I can repair it for you.
- We can rescue?
Ooh! (bangs)
That's not bad.
- If you put Italian tomato sauce la torrente.
- What's in the tomato sauce?
- It's tomato, it's Italian one.
A little bit of basil, and we put this mozzarella
we receive two time a week from Italy.
E a touch of Parmesan cheese.
And after, we put olive oil from Puglia,
is out of Italy as well.
- Wow.
- This time, we take the tool, add to the fire.
This is a proper Neapolitan oven.
All the material is come from Napoli.
The floor of the oven is stone from volcano.
I make the best dough, if I cook in the electric oven,
it change the taste.
Think of the pizza like Caesar.
There we go.
- How long will that cook for?
- Now the pizza is cooking 90 seconds.
- 90 seconds?
Wow.
- We check is it burnt or no.
When cook already, I take the peel and I leave it down.
It's don't burn the pizza.
- Okay.
- This is margarita, is a proper Neapolitan pizza.
Come over there.
- Okay.
- Turn, and go slowly, slowly.
Now start to turn.
Okay. (laughs)
- Ooh.
- Let me see
if it cook or down, no.
Is still uncook.
Okay, we wait.
- It's so cool.
- Check the pizza again.
Now take off.
Turn for this side.
Is okay, is not bad for kids.
- Not bad for kids?
- It's kid-sized, yeah.
- I think it looks good.
I mean it's not as perfect as round as yours,
but what do you think?
- For the first time is not bad.
Just here is a little bit more deep,
here is a little bit more thin.
Let me see how you cook.
Is good, maybe is better than my one. (laughs)
Let's go for taste.
- Let's go for it.
- Like this, don't do like this because everything go down.
- This is the proper way to eat it.
- In Naples we don't use knife and fork.
- Mm, that's revolutionized how I eat pizza.
This is keeping it hot!
- And you can feel the taste of the cheese,
the taste of the basil, you can feel
the taste of the Parmesan.
- It's so light and crispy and juicy?
I've never eaten a pizza and thought it's juicy.
- Maybe you eat the pizza but not Neapolitan pizza.
- Mm!
- I want to show you how we eat in Naples.
^Pizza portagoglio and in English is pizza wallet, eat.
- Oh my god. (laughs)
- We eat in the street, when you do shopping,
when we do everything.
^A portafoglio
- A por-ta-foy-yo.
^- Portafoglio
- Pizza a por-at-foy-oh?
- Portagoflio, yeah, is okay! (cheers)
(lightearted music)